Hawkins Christmas market lies in the
heart of the historic old town around
the City Hall more than half two stalls
sell Christmas decorations and gifts but
there are also plenty of culinary
attractions such as mulled wine and
punch along with hearty savory food and
sweet gingerbread cookies and often
specialty aachen our printin as they're
called here is a giant gingerbread man
are the star attraction you have to try
the spice flavored cookies I know the
normal ones from home but the ones with
spices are something special night's
darkness mulled wine and something tasty
to eat for me that's the essence of a
Christmas market this is what the market
looks like during the day in the center
the City Hall built on the foundation of
Charlemagne's Palace the catch off
square and Aachen Cathedral are situated
south of City Hall
the unesco-listed building is the city's
most famous landmark
the novus bakery operates one of the 150
stalls it's been producing Hocking
gingerbread according to the original
recipe since 1858 and today they also
come with nuts almonds chocolate fondant
icing or even in the shape of
Charlemagne himself how kind of printin
have to be made within the city limits
that has to do with rules which exist in
Germany linking the product to its
geographical origin this means the
designation of origin is protected
routes at the back of the stand Buren
Schroder is demonstrating how to make
dome Stetson Aachen cookies filled with
marzipan the exact recipe is a carefully
guarded secret but the brown dough
includes flour and baking powder and
three different kinds of sugar syrup
icing sugar and rock sugar and of course
spices aniseed cloves coriander cinnamon
and allspice each Baker has his or her
own special mixture next the dough has
to be rolled out the traditional normal
printing keep for a long time because
they don't include any ingredients that
can spoil like eggs cream milk or butter
after 14 minutes in the oven the cookie
dough is ready and it can be decorated
with nuts or covered with chocolate what
is this called Clinton Clinton okay it's
nice I think it's got some nuts in it
and I thought it's a chocolate but it's
a mix of a chocolate and something else
it's nice we have the similar Japanese
sweet like this one and softwa and the
hard one and cinnamon flavor so we like
it no my style it's like to Christmas
taste
if you want to escape the Christmas
hustle and bustle you can visit Aachen
Cathedral most tourists want to
experience something of the city's long
history as well as the Christmas market
they found it really cute here this cozy
old town and they liked the fact that
there is no trashy stuff and none of the
bustle of the Christmas Fair the shops
in the winding narrow streets are also
in the Christmas mood most printin are
sold at this time of year but they're
available all year round there's even a
statue featuring the gingerbread
specialty in front of fund and dollar
one of Atkins oldest cafes inside the
walls are decorated with wooden biscuit
molds they were used to shape a
forerunner of today's printin which
arrived in Aachen from neighboring
Belgium in the 16th century and then
developed from there the cookies are
named after the English word to print
the mould is stamped into the dough
as darkness falls it starts feeling more
and more Christmassy the market begins
to fill up and even if you're not
feeling like having anything sweet you
can't go for a day in Aachen without
seeing gingerbread cookies somewhere